Speaker 1: A couple of things I did not get
to this week.
Mypillow founder and CEO Mike Lindell.
Was coping with the mounting losses on Tuesday
by simply saying it's all stolen.
It is all fraud as it started to become clearer
and clearer on Tuesday night.
There is no red wave.
There is like a delayed red ripple maybe.
And we're still waiting for some of the results.
The Victory Channel brought him on.
I have no idea what that is, they said, Sir
Mike Pillow, please explain what's happening.
And Mike Pillow said, Listen, they're stealing
everything.
That's what's going on.
Speaker 2: Mike, tell us what's going on.
Speaker 1: By the way, the idea of even asking
pillow what's going on is hilarious.
They do.
Here is what he says.
Speaker 2: Well, it's it's it's kind of what
I expected.
They're stealing everything.
Just due to Herschel Walker's race alone,
over 200,000 votes have been injected into
his opponent.
Speaker 1: They've been injected like bleach.
Folks, these are obvious.
How many times?
How many times can they repeat the same stuff
and people will fall for it?
Injection now of votes.
Speaker 2: To get to this runoff stage.
Are they stole the governor's race in with
mastriano in Pennsylvania?
Speaker 1: No mastriano simply lost.
Speaker 2: Sheen, an early injection of 90,000
votes by the computers.
Kari Lake They're trying to steal hurt.
Speaker 1: So everything is stolen.
Everything is stolen.
This is really the epitome of brain worms,
but it's also the epitome of.
If you have a hammer and all you have is a
hammer and you believe the hammer is almost
like a god.
Everything is a nail.
And this is all they have left.
The truth.
Is not something they can accept.
The truth is, Trump hasn't been particularly
good for the party.
One in 2016.
2018 wasn't so good.
2020 wasn't good at all.
And 2022 was much worse than expected.
It's not fraud.
It's not injections or sautéing or grilling
or smoking or curing ballots.
It's not salting and peppering of ballots.
It's not it's not any of it.
Trump is convincing these voters to select
terrible candidates for the primaries.
A lot of them are now losing.
It's genuinely that simple, and they are throwing
anything they can at the wall.
And now what it is, is the epitome of if we
won, it was rigged.
If we lost.
I'm sorry.
If we won, it was fair.
If we lost, it was rigged.
Even on the same ballots.
And that's one of the funny things.
You know, a few people emailed me over the
last couple of days about what I tweeted years
ago now about how is it that they're saying
on the same ballot, the presidential results
were rigged, but the Senate and House results
are trustworthy when Trump lost, but their
House or Senate candidates won.
And it's starting to be the exact same level
of incoherence again.
Why anybody would go to my pillow for analysis,
I genuinely don't know